you're such a fun person to ask these
big questions with well I hope I could
give some answers that are interesting
well because because of you've sharpened
your brain's ability to explore some of
the most some of the questions them many
signs is actually afraid of even
touching which is fascinating and I
think you're in that sense ultimately a
great scientist through this process of
sharpening your brain well I don't know
if I am a scientist I think you know
science is a way of knowing and there
are a lot of questions I investigate
that are not scientific questions on
like minefield we have definitely done
scientific experiments and studies that
had hypotheses and all that but you know
not to be too like Precious about what
does the word science mean but I think I
would just describe myself as curious
and I hope that that curiosity is
contagious so to you the scientific
method is deeply connected to science
because your curiosity took you to
asking questions to me asking a good
question even if you feel society feels
that it's not a question within the
reach of science currently to me that
asking the question is the biggest step
of the scientific process the scientific
method is the second part and that may
be what traditionally is called science
but to me asking the questions being
brave enough to ask the questions being
curious and not constrained by what
you're supposed to think is is just true
what it means to be a scientist to me
it's certainly a huge part of what it
means to be a human if I were to say you
know what I don't believe in forces I
think that when I push on a massive
object a ghost leaves my body and enters
the object I'm pushing and these ghosts
happen to just get really lazy when
they're around massive things and that's
why F equals MA oh and by the way the
laziness of the ghosts is in proportion
to the mass of the objects so boom
proved me wrong every experiment well
you can never find the ghost and so none
of that theory is scientific but once I
start
saying can I see the ghost Why should
there be a ghost and if there aren't
ghosts what might I expect and I start
to do different tests to see is this
falsifiable are there things that should
happen if there are ghosts throw things
that shouldn't happen and do they you
know what do I observe now I'm thinking
scientifically I don't think of science
as wow a picture of a black hole that's
just a photograph that's an image that's
data that's a sensory and perception
experience science is how we got that
and how we understand it and how we
believe in it and how we reduce our
uncertainty around what it means but I
would say I'm deeply within the
scientific community and and sometimes
disheartened by the elitism of the
thinking sort of not allowing yourself
to think outside the box so allowing the
possibility of going against the
conventions of science I think is is a
beautiful part of some of the greatest
scientists in history I don't know I
I'm impressed by scientists everyday and
revolutions in our knowledge of the
world occur
only under very special circumstances it
is very scary to challenge conventional
thinking and and and risky because let's
go back to elitism and ego right if you
just say you know what I believe in the
spirits of my body and all forces are
actually created by invisible creatures
that that that transfer themselves
between objects
if you ridicule every other theory and
say that you're what you're you're
correct then ego gets involved and you
just don't go anywhere but the
fundamentally the question of well what
is a force isn't incredibly important we
need to have that conversation but it
needs to be done in this very political
way of like let's be respectful of
everyone and let's realize that we're
all learning together and not shutting
out other people and so when you look at
a lot of revolutionary ideas they were
not accepted right away and you know
Galileo had a couple of problems with
the authorities and later thinkers
Descartes was like all right look I kind
of agree with Galileo but I'm gonna have
to not say that I'll have to create and
invent and write different things that
keep me from being in trouble but we
still slowly made progress revolutions
are difficult in all forms and certainly
in size
you